so anxiety is rooted in biology it's
evolutionarily based in that we have our
own fight-or-flight responses some of it
is very old and triggered from the deep
part of our brain that is the oldest
part the fight-or-flight response and
then some of it comes from the cortex
which evolved much later and that's
worried and that might be 21st century
anxiety because there's a lot we can
find to worry about these days are we
going to make enough money are we going
to get the right job are we going to
provide for our families we're going to
do the right thing what could go wrong
in the world so many things can trigger
anxiety just by walking through everyday
life but the good news is our systems
are also set up to handle it the beauty
of anxiety and the system that we have
of anxiety that's all throughout our
nervous system is that it evolved to
protect us so there's two components to
it the oldest being the amygdala which
is deep in the brain in the reptilian
part of our brain signals whether we
should fight something flee something or
freeze when it goes awry is when it's
perceiving immediate danger that really
isn't there somebody's heart starts to
race and they think oh my goodness is
something wrong with me that's panic and
that can send somebody into a panic
attack which is the clinical
manifestation of the fight-or-flight
response the other thing with anxiety is
again as we evolved and became thinking
human beings and started building
communities and you know cities and and
civilizations is our brain evolved and
there's the cortex it's within the
cortex that we think it's within that
system that we worry and so we can worry
ourselves in two states of anxiety where
we are fraught and not knowing what to
do and we actually get stuck with
anxiety and so we're tense and irritable
and upset so what makes the difference
between everyday anxiety which we all
experience anxiety
is perfectly normal in any form it's
perfectly normal having your heart
racing because somebody is walking
behind you and you don't know who it is
it's kind of normal but if you let that
happen to you when you're sitting alone
at home and you start having panic then
that gets out of control and worried
about what to do in the future is normal
for all of us but if we can't move our
minds off of that and on to what do I
need to take care of here and let me
enjoy my family while we're doing this
thing and activity and I'll
problem-solve that later then that
becomes a problem and that may become an
anxiety issue what was great from the
1990s all the way through to now is it
sort of was the age of anxiety in terms
of mental health treatment development
the 1990s opened up lots of treatment
funded here in the United States by the
National Institutes of mental health and
then also in other other countries did
similar things where cognitive
behavioral therapy became the most
tested and developed treatment and found
to be the most effective psychological
or talk therapy for managing anxiety and
managing anxiety of all kinds obsessive
compulsive disorder panic disorder
generalized anxiety disorder and so
forth
social phobia the number one anxiety
disorder in kids and adults cognitive
behavioral therapy is great for that so
we put a lot of work into that
developing these treatments and
perfecting them and then also there are
great medications actually that were
developed through that time the
combination of the two treatments works
best for many people who are debilitated
by anxiety but these treatments are
excellent and they are available but not
widespread so this is where again
technology comes in because technology
has allowed us to put some of the skills
training and some of the aspects of
cognitive behavior therapy into apps
into online programs and such that then
can reach hard to reach individuals and
people who don't have access to serve
there's some very exciting work being
done today throughout the country and
around the world in terms of anxiety
research looking at in different ways
what aspects of the brain are working
with the amygdala and the cortex in
terms of turning anxiety on when it
doesn't need to keeping it going what
are the triggers for anxiety on all
different levels from genetic all the
way through to what's in the environment
and then helping to sharpen our
treatments and to direct themselves to
those mechanisms and tamp down those
mechanisms so that can help a person
probably earlier in the cycle of anxiety
earlier in life and such and to manage
so neuroscience is coming on with all
sorts of ways of looking at what are
some new technologies and including
different types of computer apps and
stuff that target anxiety processes and
then there are also ways of
disseminating treatments and reaching
people that we are working with so I
think the big exciting part of what
we're seeing over the next 10 to 20
years is going to be much more
dissemination of more targeted and I
think more effective treatments for
people that are going to be coming on
board and going to be disseminated
through many different means not just
through the your local therapist like me
but also through many different types of
technologies that are going to be made
available
you